here's a story out of new york
a 10 year old child
has just become the youngest transgender
model to walk the runway
at new york's fashion week
this young boy
goes by noella he participated in the
trans clothing company show this was
created by the designer mel atkinson uh
this according to metro
and noella this little boy who who's
who the adults in his life are dressing
up to be a little girl
says it feels good that i'm already
inspiring trans kids to be themselves
now obviously what transgenderism does
is the opposite they encourage kids and
all people not to be themselves to be
other people or to pretend to be other
people to have a little boy pretend to
be a little girl or vice versa
i'm all for encouraging people to be
themselves
and not even just themselves as they are
but to be a perfect good version of
themselves
all people can they can go bad or they
can go good they can
get into a lot of vice and sin and bad
stuff or they can do good stuff pursue
virtue sanctity holiness
and we should we should encourage the
latter not the former it's not just that
you're born
some people are born good some people
are born bad that's not true we have
free will we have a conception of what's
good and what's bad
okay and we and we can know something
about that and pursue that here we're
getting the worst possible version we're
encouraging people to only pursue really
bad stuff and then to just pretend to be
totally different than they are outright
how on earth does a 10 year old kid wind
up doing a drag dance at new york
fashion week obviously because this poor
little boy has pervert parents
his current guardians that's how it's
described in the article
i don't even know what the relationship
of these adults are to the kid i just
know that they're perverts rey and dee
mcmaher
told the metro
that noella who's this little boy began
socially transitioning at the age of
four
so so you read that you say rey and d
that sounds like normal people right but
i know they're not normal people because
they're transiting their little
four-year-old so of course these guys
are both guys or girls i don't know what
they are are both sexual deviants they
identify as non-binary and so whose
fault is this the primary fault is the
fault of the parents
or i don't know the parents the current
guardians as this is ambiguously
described in the paper
but the parents are the fault of us
that's really what this is about we
can't just say those guys are perverts
or girls or whatever they are we can't
just say they're perverts they're
this is their child abuse yeah it is
they're primarily responsible but we let
this happen
we let this happen how on earth did
these people adopt a child or do it or
through surrogacy create a child right i
actually don't know if it's two guys or
two girls or a guy and a girl the fact
that i don't know that is our fault
politically because we've radically
redefined marriage so we have no idea
what marriage means we tolerate all
sorts of sexual degeneracy so men can
pretend to be women and women can be
pretend to be men and they can pretend
to be ambiguous people are having a
surgery called sexual nullification that
means they just chop off their genitals
entirely and we tolerate this not only
do we tolerate this we celebrate this
and if you in any way criticize it
you're called a hater and you can be
ostracized from society i'm not sure
that this video will remain on youtube
you know i broadcast my show in part on
youtube i'm not sure that this will even
be allowed to be kept up
because i don't think that these pervs
should be allowed within 300 yards of a
child and i don't think they should be
able to pretend that their union is a
marriage and i don't think they should
be able to pretend that whichever one of
them is a man
either or none of them as a man is a
girl or vice versa or that they're
neither
that's our fault we let it get this far
we in the political community
we let the libs go this far because so
many conservatives what did they say
well it doesn't affect me
i think government should get out of the
marriage business entirely well i don't
know what people do in their bedroom
between consenting adults that's none of
my business i don't i think this is my
business i don't want kids on drag on
drag
red carpets i don't want kids little
boys dancing around like little girls
for the satisfaction of perverts at new
york's fashion week i don't want these
yale psychopaths to be able to trans
i think that's a political problem
that's why the government's always
involved in marriage by the way because
marriage is the fundamental political
institution and the state meaning the
political community obviously has an
interest and obviously always has some
kind of say in how to raise the next
generation
that's what it is that's what marriage
is marriage is a lifelong bond a union
between a man and a woman for the sake
of the generation the procreation and
the education of children
we have a say about that
or we should
or we just let this
we let this go
and i do i blame the libs
but i expected of the libs
here my my special ire is for those
squishy conservatives
who let it get this far because they
didn't have the moral clarity or even if
they did have the moral clarity in a lot
of cases they didn't have the moral
courage to say no
sorry ray and d mcmahor you don't get to
pretend that your non-binary union is a
marriage and you don't get to either
purchase a child or adopt a child or
rent a woman's womb and create a child
in this way that establishes the
domination of technology over the origin
and destiny of the human person and you
it's not about you you don't get to do
your weird stuff sorry there are rules
and standards and we are going to defend
them hey michael i listen to you on ben
shapiro show the other day he got to the
mailbag part where you're talking about
how
we shouldn't give the death penalty to
rapists because that would incentivize
them to kill their victims
but
i feel like that's contradictory to
things you've said in the past about how
laws
affect people's behavior because
culture's downstream of politics
and if you make harsher punishments for
crimes then that makes people less
likely to do crime
so
why shouldn't we make harsher
punishments for rape i.e capital
punishment death penalty
so that less people would rape
but you said on ben shapiro show that it
wouldn't well you didn't say it wouldn't
decrease rape you just said it would
incentivize people to kill their victims
but the implication there is that it
wouldn't decrease the amount of rapes it
would just increase the amount of people
who are raped and murdered
can you explain that to me
well you were the show thank you very
much you were right up until that very
moment and you even caught yourself and
you said well okay you didn't say that
it wouldn't uh
decrease rape but you know but the
implication was but no the
your implication the thing that you
inferred is not something that i implied
yes it is true harsher punishments for
rape would disincentivize rape
and because the law is a teacher you
would get less rape
sure
but at the same time simultaneously you
would incentivize the rapists who do
commit rape to kill their victims if the
punishment for murder and the punishment
for rape were the same
because
the rapist
in a regime in which rape is punished
less severely than murder the rapist has
some incentive not to kill his victim
even though by not killing his victim he
increases the chances that he'll be
caught because the victim could go to
the police and say what happened
but in a regime in which rape and murder
get the exact same punishment then the
the rapist has absolutely no incentive
whatsoever other than his own obviously
malfunctioning conscience or the
conscience that he doesn't really listen
to not to murder his victim so you
create an incentive for the rapist to do
that
so what we have here is a balancing of
different incentives and different
desirable outcomes
and what we have to apply here is
prudence
i agree
if if you gave the death penalty to
rapists you might and very likely would
reduce the total number of rapes you
would never get the total number of
rapes to zero but you you probably would
reduce the number of rapes but you would
increase the number of rape victims who
are murdered and i don't think that's
worth the cost
so from the position of prudence
i would say it is worth reducing
somewhat the punishment for rape
if you are going to decrease the number
of rape victims who are murdered
even if
by doing so you somewhat increase the
incentives to commit a rape
or the prevalence of rape again i mean
we're
we can't really know the degree to which
these things would shift statistically
but even granting the premise i just
think from a prudential point of view by
decreasing the number of rape victims
who are murdered that would be worth
tolerating
getting rid of one of the disincentives
to rape but it's a it's a judgment call
it's a call for prudence it's not an
exact science that's why statescraft
statecraft rather is
much more of an art than it is a sort of
science that can just be plugged into a
computer and formulated by a robot i'm
so glad you like that clip now before
you go look we got over a million
subscribers i love that i want a
trillion okay and the first step to a
trillion subscribers is you clicking
that bell so ring it click it ding dong
what a what a bing bong we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you